college football fans have taken to
chanting f joe biden in the stands this
is a uh during the games
and saturday marked the second straight
weekend of presidential taunts old rose
sports identified at least four
instances of the chance f joe biden at
college gains
during the weekend of september 4 2021
the chance broke out at coastal carolina
university virginia tech auburn
university and texas a m the chat bro uh
chat chant broke out again
amid the student section of the auburn
alabama state game on september 11
donald trump jr predicted that this
trend will continue he said the biden
presidency has gone so bad that the
media can't run
cover for him anymore even at this last
week's 9 11 event that took place do you
know barack obama spoke do you know joe
biden spoke i'm sorry do you know what
uh
uh president bush spoke you know who
didn't speak this week about it joe
biden speak didn't speak this week and
they say it's one of two reasons
republicans are saying he didn't speak
because
uh uh
everybody was gonna boom and he was
gonna get destroyed like you know
the fact that their team doesn't want to
say anything even democrats are saying
they just thought it wouldn't be a good
look for him to talk right now it's
better off for him to just kind of take
it easy but what do you think about
these chants chant chanting your
president f joe biden is this a good
thing is this a bad look what do you
think and i'm gonna remove my uh any
biases whatsoever but the same [ __ ] was
happening at different places regarding
donald trump two years ago yeah so
lebron called him a chump okay so like
let's stop making this a big i'm not
saying we are but
cool drunk college kids in the south are
screaming or f joe biden cool
liberals in boston were doing the same
thing for trump this is such a
non-story for me it's the same thing
that happened a few years ago is it a
good thing though
or is it irrelevant like freedom of
speech do it if you want to do it go for
it she gives a [ __ ] okay
drunk college kids in the south at a
football game do you have a strong
different opinion look man i think uh i
think what you're seeing again is the
stratification of look when you have xi
jing biden get on air on thursday and
threaten the entire
country he gets on and he threatens uh
duly elected fairly elected governors if
you won't do what i say and if you won't
subject that subjugates your citizens in
the way i demand i will get you out of
the way my patience is wearing thin this
isn't about your freedom you know what
double barrel two of these to uh to you
uh xi jing biden and and i'm saying this
as a guy that hated george bush i know
everybody thinks i'm like a right wing
guy on this but like i hated george bush
to me george bush was the second worst
president of all time behind buchanan
buchanan is the worst president of all
time by far all right he let the country
fall apart he basically gave up in his
uh in his term he was like screw it i
don't want to deal with this and he let
the country rip in half thank god for
abraham lincoln following him okay then
bush inherits a surplus
and turns it into a deficit and gets us
into a war that costs us 300 million
dollars a day george bush inherited a
surplus people don't want to give uh
clinton credit he we left us with a
surplus okay
we're talking about janet yellen raise
we had a surplus in our lifetime like
it's like we act like this is insane by
the way that's that's what i became i
guess a fan of democrats i thought
clinton was a g and and i was a fan
bush was objectively horrible and the
fact that bush speaks at 9 11 doesn't
sit with me very well either to be
honest with you but
you can't say that pat is a big fan of
george bush
god bless you they write letters to each
other pat would probably have a
different appearance george bush needs
to you did meet george w bush you are
for you he was a great guy but listen
this is this is not this is not about
whether
i get along with anybody i agree or
disagree with for the most part i get
along with anybody it doesn't matter i
sit down i can talk to anybody no this
isn't about that this is about
is this a good idea for this to be
taking place for me it tells me a couple
different things i've never liked it
never liked it to get to that point
never to make that be okay i was so
furious when
uh what's his name said uh hey trump he
wasn't gonna come anyways no when he
said hey chump he wasn't gonna come
anyways and lebron called the president
hate chump and duran said i'm not going
to the white house and then stephen a
smith and max kellerman went back and
forth and will kane disagreed with both
of them wilkin ended up getting fired
now he's got a job at fox news anyways
i'm not a fan of what's going on here
but what it does tell you is the
following wait because it's
disrespectful or will kane said uh uh
you know you should respect the office
yeah but these guys are like wow you
know
anyways here's here's where i go with
this what i go with this is demographics
marketing it tells you who the nba fan
is uh who the audience is it tells you
what college football is college
football is a conservative fan base if
that's what they're saying well in the
south pad is that these are by the way
these are not small markets you're not
texas i'm sorry you're not talking about
first cities
virginia tech is not a republican
university buddy virginia tech you're
saying as a republican university now
i'm just saying it's in the south auburn
university coastal carolina oh it's in
the south
it doesn't matter it's about l.a you're
saying drunk
a university in the south automatically
everybody's going to be categorized
that's not what i'm saying
that's in the south we get this the
disregard are we not aware of
the south usually votes republican
you're smart guy you know this already
the university is different because
university people don't go to university
from the city there and people come from
all across the country so it's not like
yeah asheville but every city in the
south is all i'm saying
all i'm saying to you is it's
the audience that's doing it it's
interesting that's all i'm saying the
audience that's doing it is interesting
i've never been a fan i don't care if
it's joe trump i don't think i know we
got to wrap up here i want to get your
we can obviously do monday morning
quarterback next time something we've
been talking about for over a year now
the gavin newsom recall is today yep do
you have any strong feelings or or uh
prognostications on this there's a lot
of things you're hearing from both sides
the one side is saying there's no way
it's gonna happen obama pelosi everybody
showed up to save news from everybody's
commenting on the other side larry elder
california has five million more
democrats than republicans you need to
know the stats on that as well uh in the
recall side a bunch of republicans that
were going and voting they said you
already voted like i didn't vote and so
this lady's asking you know five other
ladies that were in the voting place did
you guys yeah it said i voted but i
didn't vote are you democrat or problem
we're that we're republican wait a
minute you're republican i said the
machine that you already voted yeah but
we didn't vote
you know again going back to some of the
stuff that's taking place there you
think they're going to let newsome
well there's only two times this has
happened in the history of america i
think one of them is davis and the other
one is some some i don't know who the
other person maybe we have uh governor
meet kevin paffrath on again when he
went him and gerard might go to lunch i
think him and gerard need to do
podcasting we'll do a podcast right
outside of one of his super happy fun
time concentration camps i think he's
necessary for california fyi the real
quick i know you got to leave you
actually asked an incredible question
yesterday if tupac was alive today yeah
50th 50th birthday birthday was
yesterday right yeah that's it do you
where do you think tupac would stand
today in today's i think he was very i
think he'd be one of the biggest voices
in america i think he'd be one of the
biggest voices but
he would either be an aoc type of person
because he could be an aoc type of
person you know i i see that depends if
he made a lot of wealth he may be a
jay-z type of person
i just don't think we're too powerful he
would definitely be a blm type of person
definitely yeah 100 percent out of that
i think he'd be very blm and i think
he'd be very very aoc until this moment
he's so anti-authority and he is so
anti-establishment i think this last
would have kind of pissed him off
something yeah he could have been
accountable you've got to realize he
also said a lot of stuff about his own
side so he wasn't one that was afraid to
push back on his own community he was
not one that he would be a very
interesting person well there is a
chance kidding me the song he wrote
about uh hit him up not hit him up the
start has got a baby he's got a baby
again
about the community anyways
there is a chance he's still alive
i gotta go so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]